who is on your list let's just go top
three goats you're number one let's say
you're number one take you out GSP John
Jones now you know I'm gonna say Habib
those three when I sit back I've been
pondering about this too and I have a
lot of more athletes who are who are the
good as well you know hear mercyhood was
right there he is the greatest common
athlete of all time uh gold little melis
fly away depending the belt Spanaway
they're better than they'll come back
and find a win about again you know the
only thing I'll say from here is like
I'd love to see him get a submission
when I look at all three of those guys
GSP he's knocked people out he's got a
submission he's got a decision uh Jon
Jones same thing same thing even with
heavy metal you know I I don't know if
he's actually a kid somebody with I'm
cold those guys have showcase everything
for me